NARRATOR: The measurements
of the length and width
of the perimeter of the
Great Pyramid correspond
to an exact fraction of both
the latitude and longitude
measurements at the equator.
Scaled up, this means the Great
Pyramid directly corresponds
to the circumference
of the equator
as well as the measurement
from the equator to the pole.
Making it a scale model of
the northern hemisphere.
Recently, using
satellite technology,
researchers have realized
yet another advanced formula
encoded in the design.
If you take the location
of the Great Pyramid
as a coordinate, this number
sequence of this coordinate
matches exactly the speed of
light traveling through space
measured in meters per second.
This is amazing stuff.
When you consider the
vast amount of information
about the Earth that's encoded
into the Great Pyramid,
you can't just dismiss all
of this as pure coincidence.
NARRATOR: Although, the
Great Pyramid at Giza
offers an astounding example
of encoded information,
other sites around the world,
such as the Mesoamerican
pyramids and the
ziggurats of Mesopotamia,
have also been
found to be aligned
to exact cardinal points and
embody mathematical concepts.
These buildings were
built under divine guidance.
This is a mark of the gods.
They put certain things
in these buildings
to let us know they are not
entirely of human origin.
They represent something
larger than we are.
The builders
wanted to make sure
that a future generation
would know that there
is a discrepancy in knowledge.
And what I'm
suggesting is that all
these ancient structures
are calling cards
left by extraterrestrials.
NARRATOR: Ancient
astronaut theorists
suggest that evidence of
extraterrestrial intervention
in the construction
and placement
of these incredible
structures can
also be found by examining
their alignments with the stars.
If I wanted to leave behind a
piece of evidence that suggests
where I'm from, one
way, for example,
is by creating
monuments that are
in the shape of constellations.
In ancient Egypt,
the three pyramids
are aligned with the
constellation of Orion's belt.
The pyramids are not the
only monuments that have
this particular configuration.
NARRATOR: The ancient site
of Teotihuacan in Mexico
also contains three pyramids
that are oriented to match up
with the belt stars of Orion.
And other sites
throughout the world
have been found to have similar
astronomical alignments.